do you think you're on solid
constitutional ground
here well I'm we're going to see there
was this shooting in New Mexico and then
uh Governor Luan Grisham Luan Grisham uh
she basically said she can suspend the
Constitution that people can't have uh
people can't carry their guns and blah
blah blah it's it's so insane it's like
how do I even have to tell this story
here she is trying to defend her
decision but we also have governor
the constitution of the of New Mexico
and the Constitution of the United
States and you're an attorney do you
think you're on solid constitutional
ground
here well I'm we're going to see I mean
look I wouldn't do it if I didn't think
I had the right I have the right where
is the right where is the right in the
state of New Mexico public health it's a
suspension it's not a ban and we'll see
what all of these Court actions do it's
a suspension not a band it's just like
this temporary thing like two weeks to
stop stop the spread oh Fourth Amendment
right to peaceably assemble oh well for
two years we kind of didn't have that
now as I pointed out yesterday the part
the like cynical version of all of this
is she can get away with anything unless
they stop her from getting away with it
we can have guaranteed rights but they
only work the laws that we have only
work if we defend them but if enough
people don't defend that oh well they
told us to stay in our house again they
told us to wear masks again they told us
we can't have guns again like it only
works if we believe in the
system